this is the Swedish Embassy in Baghdad
under attack by protesters
hundreds stormed the building and set it
on fire in the early hours of Thursday
morning
the protest was in response to Swedish
police granting application for a public
meeting outside the Iraqi Embassy in
Stockholm
where an Iraqi Refugee saw one mamaka
reportedly planned to burn the Quran and
the Iraqi flag
is a former member of Iraqi militia who
caused outrage after burning the Quran
last month
[Music]
we demand the Swedish government and the
Iraqi government to stop this type of
act it's against the human right and the
emotions of the people in Islam it's
provocative for all Muslims they are
hurting all Muslim feelings we demand
the religious associations to stop this
act
the demonstration in Baghdad was called
by supporters of Shia politician muktada
al-sader
he's one of the most powerful figures in
Iraq who commands hundreds of thousands
of followers
wants to defend Islam the Quran and the
message to the Iraqi people we are
currently in the month of Moran revolt
against criminals enemies of the Quran
and currently we are in the middle of a
fight
the Swedish foreign Ministry said all
its Embassy staff are safe and condemned
the attack
Iraq's foreign Ministry issued a similar
condemnation
it says it will conduct a swift
investigation to identify those
responsible and hold them to account
Fenton Monaghan Al Jazeera